[Music]
hey everybody pookie's over here talking
to you yes she ran past my poop
i don't know what she's talking about uh
so hey everybody trying to turn the damn
chat on so i can see and it's not
it's not showing me anything in the chat
this thing's [ __ ] up well yeah it must
be youtube's [ __ ] up
why it's working
i don't know what maybe it's just maybe
youtube just don't like you in
particular
[Laughter]
anyway go ahead and start a show jenny
all right see camp guy in there see zach
in there zach says what's up guys my
depressed and sore ass is sitting in the
atlanta airport our trip kind of what
tits up so i'm going home alone oh no
i'm sorry to hear that
yeah cause i was gonna say you don't i
don't we don't usually see you on the
matinee shows maybe you just show up
others but i always kind of feel like
you mostly just came for the main shows
but uh so yeah so you want to talk about
dark man three yeah
yeah i was gonna say something what's
that because the stream has been so good
you might be able to uh raise the uh
the the graphics level
on the thing because uh i'm looking at
it on the smart tv man and we look like
[ __ ]
just look blocky
yeah i'm trying man yeah well you know i
guess i'll do that right now but yeah
obviously i can't later later we can uh
we'll just remind you we'll do it before
the main show tomorrow right it's just
we're on a land cable now so
yeah the stream's been good
since that land cable
yeah we haven't really had any problems
no problem since i got that like i said
15 and a half things raised
yeah i mean i hope so i don't really
want to like attempt fade or anything
yeah
i guess so i didn't i didn't like lower
it all that much but
i did lower it down time uh so yeah so
last night uh you know if you've been
here the last couple days we've been
doing the dark man trilogy because
shutter just added it a couple uh days
ago or a couple weeks ago rather
and uh last night we watched dark man 3
die dark man die yeah
now i think i mentioned
i'm not sure this was on the wikipedia
page for dark man 2 but it didn't
mention it on dark man 3.
i heard that dark man 3 was actually
shot before dark man 2
but they released the one that became
dark man 2 the one with larry drake in
it in 1995 and then this one was
released in 1996.
so i don't know if that's entirely true
or not but that's what i read it doesn't
mention it on the page on the wikipedia
page for part three but it does on part
two
you know oh it just wasn't ready in time
i'm not really sure i don't and honestly
now that i'm seeing it
i do kind of feel like because i was
watching part three with that in mind
and i was kind of like i can see how
this was
shot more like right after the second
one like it felt more like a part two it
felt more like a part two and then the
third one was just kind of like hey
here's this guy we thought was gone all
this time and then he came back and then
he dies in a big explosion at the end so
you could kind of see like how they did
it but then for whatever reason they
decided to switch the order but that's
okay it doesn't really because this one
ends like the story's just beginning
so watching them because it ends similar
to the first one where it's just kind of
like you know he saves a woman like a
family and then he's like well here's my
[ __ ] up looking face i can't i gotta
go fight crime i can't like involve
anybody else in my [ __ ] yeah and he
gets like goes off into the sunset so
yeah whereas the third where is the
second one like actually ends with the
bad guy like getting blown up
and [ __ ] like that i was uh
you know yesterday i was saying you know
usually part three sucks and uh i was
expecting this one to be pretty bad it's
good i think it's the i think it's
as good as the first one
i actually likes this one a bit better
than the second one
the second one's good too yeah uh and i
did like that larry drake was in the
second one like because he made a really
good villain and i like that they had
him and they focused on him in the
second one as i mentioned yesterday
but this one
feels more like the first one in the
sense that it's focused more on dark man
and on his kind of like emotional
journey there's a bad guy there's a
similar kind of plot going on
but it actually is more focused on him
and on his work
and he's in
in it most of the time rather than it
focusing it does focus on the bad guys a
little bit but dark man the man
but uh the the story drew me in a lot
better
yeah than than yeah
part two is just kind of like a
free-for-all [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] crazy it's good but it's just
it it's insane this one's a little more
chilled out and it kind of
pulls you more into the dark man
character
this might have been i think this is
supposed to be part two
i think it initially was supposed to be
part two and i could see that yeah i
could see that
because yeah i i liked it a lot too i i
actually liked it um
quite a bit more than i was expecting to
let okay everything is consistent it's
the same quality uh it's the same basic
tone and motif
um it's consistent there's no big drop
off in quality or anything from uh from
dark man 2. and really not not even
really a big drop off from one
one has
some of that
evil dead feeling to it you know what i
mean but this so does this one
you know it's it's close it's it's there
they're all
yeah i mean the first one had a little
bit more of a comic book sensibility to
it yeah um whereas the set whereas two
and three were kind of more
straightforward action movies with just
like a little sprinkling of comic book
stuff on top yeah but that's okay yeah
um it's a different director sam raimi
was again the executive producer on this
but it's the same director brad for may
as the second one who i guess was like a
tv guy like he was a tv director
cinematographer something like that um i
did like that they kept
even like through all three movies
even though i'm sure when they made the
first one i don't think they were
expecting it to be a trilogy necessarily
but i like that all three movies had
like pretty much the exact same
opening credits yeah like i really like
the same font same now the original
movie was danny elfman right like did
the score and uh obviously he didn't
come back for the set for the second or
third one so they got like another
composer that used some of his themes um
but you can't really tell like i said
it's still a good score and it's still
in the same
vein as the danny elfman one
another thing i noticed is that
with this one i
you know the the first dark man from
dark man one is liam neeson but he
couldn't come back because he had to go
do schindler's list and stuff
when part two came out the new dark man
i didn't really warm up to him he kind
of seemed kind of
like he had been shoot in
but this one i got the feeling for that
air that that actor doing this character
i was by i accepted him as dark man
that's why i was thinking that this
might have been supposed to be part two
had it been part two i think i could
have
i don't know
digested that new actor as being dark
man first but because he's in it more
he's in it more like because in the
second one
yeah like i said he's in it obviously
but they focused more on larry draken
and he's grant he's good yeah he's good
in it
you know uh yeah he does look like that
good looking dude that my ex-wife used
to lost billy zane
look at his lips she's always looking at
him he does like creepily like and i i
never really occurred to me before until
i was like looking at his face in the
dark movies i'm like goddamn that movie
that dude looks almost exactly like
billy zane yeah tiffany was sitting
there [ __ ] well he's got some nice
abs
damn
[ __ ] get over there
i was getting that ab jealousy
but
he's good in it uh his acting's good he
[ __ ] pulls the character off in this
third one
um a lot better than he does i think in
the second and i don't think it's
because i warmed up to him i think it's
because he's got a bigger role so you
can actually see him more
and he's more of a badass than liam
neeson he gives off more of a
threatening
vibe he's more intense i guess yeah
well you know
yeah he's the good guy
but he's got a lot of dark elements in
him you know kind of like phantom of the
opera
yeah and uh
so
you're wondering well maybe this maybe
this dude might blow and do something
bad you know you don't know
um but uh
they had a couple good angles in this
instead of ray guns they have this uh
drug dealer guy who's
hooked up with this hot
uh scientist dr chick
who's uh
smoking hot [ __ ] 90s haircut and [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
turns out she's making super steroids
yeah so of course yeah tom's like super
on board what he's like oh i want some
of those yeah
[Laughter]
and all kinds of [ __ ] steroid fun
happens you know what i mean oh god it's
terrifying you're right
he's like yeah
yeah
those dudes all start fighting each
other yeah they're all just like
smacking each other around each other
like i'm over there going uh you know
the main crime boss guy he's probably
just kind of like can you guys actually
do something useful or you're just going
to like stand here like beat the crap
out of each other right yeah
and the the boss is going like boss is
looking at his gang you know and he's
like oh all these other gangs you know i
mean any old weakling can just pick up a
pistol it's a sign of weakness you know
because with us it's about strength it's
something you could do with your fists
and they're not beating [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] they had guns too but yeah but
uh
they could take a lot of they could take
a lot of shots they could get shot up uh
they could [ __ ] super strength they
could uh match dark man in his strength
all kinds of stuff had so it's it's a
lot more fun than the ray gun angle i
think
it's more creative
yeah it allows for more fun and games
i thought the ray gun
gag in part two
was kind of samey
you know i mean kind of predictable yeah
let's make a ray gun
yeah you know let's make super steroids
and they made the super steroids on uh
on the special adrenaline that dark man
could put out through his [ __ ]
hypothalamus gland what was it yeah or
something like that yeah they got it out
of him well yeah i kind of like how they
did that because
what ends up happening in this one
is that
you have dark man now i will say that
they reused some of the footage that was
in the second one not a lot but it was
mostly just the footage of him like on
his little train car like going down to
his lair or whatever
um and him like taking off his face and
like hanging it on the coat rack and all
that
and
but i was just kind of like oh hey they
reused this from the last movie but then
i had to like think well this was back
in the 90s and it wasn't like people
nowadays that like sit and binge like
three or four movies or shows at one
time so it's like it might have been a
year or two between you seeing one and
the other so you probably wouldn't have
noticed yeah but uh yeah that was that
so what they did
they have him still working on his skin
thing which still melts after 99 minutes
so he's still trying to like get through
that barrier and then he meets uh you
know the hot doctor yeah who dude's
cheating on his wife with him yeah well
yeah you don't find out that later
because you have like
just like in the other ones you have
like the bad guy gang now the the bad
guy in this is named rooker
and he's like a drug dealer uh he's
played by jeff fahey who was in a [ __ ]
ton of stuff god damn he was in like so
many movies and so many tv shows i
remember him from psycho three
and he was in that terrible uh lawnmower
man that stephen king adaptation that
stephen king sued to have his name taken
off of he was in that yeah okay when he
says drug dealer we're not talking about
a street level drug dealer he's more he
he's like a rich guy playing piano and
then you know he's all cultured
[Laughter]
he's a dick though all right oh yeah
he's the mega dude he's more kind of
like a drug lord not really a drug
dealer but he's got a an army of
[ __ ] just white dudes who really you
look at and they're not too threatening
but he puts them on them [ __ ] roids
and they get they get [ __ ] crazy
it's good it's a good angle i thought i
thought it was yeah because because what
he figured out because the the hot
doctor yeah uh approaches dark man at
first you think she's a good guy and
she's like oh hey i was one of the
doctors that was you know
in the first movie like when you when
they fixed you
and um
we couldn't figure out because tom was
like well is she supposed to be like
jenny agather's character like from the
first one i was like well not
necessarily she could have just been
like another doctor that was there or
she could have just heard about it
somewhere else and just light her and
she
i think she lied and i don't think she
was there because she lied about
everything else yeah but so basically
she said oh i was one of the doctors so
i know that you have super strength and
i also know that you can't feel any pain
and i've developed this thing where you
can get some of your uh pain back
and uh or some of your you know some of
your feeling back
and so
he uh she seems super nice and
everything so he
lets her do it but it turns out that
she's like a stone cold thunder [ __ ]
and man like and basically is like
implants this thing in the back of his
head and then she has like essentially
an agonizer where she can like go
and like make him feel all this pain
like from far away yeah so there's so
there's that so she's like and we
extracted like all of your
all your juices and we're going to make
this super steroid with it so then we
can inject it
to all our thugs and then they'll be
super strong right and then they can
smack you around and then they were
going to sell it to uh professional
sports athletes though too so they could
win all these games yeah so it was going
to be a big commercial thing so it
wasn't just the but they were going to
use they were going to use the gang as
the test bed yeah that's the test
subject yeah so they were just kind of
like and it was like worked it worked
they got [ __ ] like i said they were
all just like slapping each other they
didn't get big they just got real strong
and real mean and they looked like they
were all tweaked out all the time maybe
i'll tweet and they just wanted to like
pull people's heads off and why not and
i was like yeah that sounds like you
yeah
as soon as they just as soon as they
juice them up a few hours later they're
out there just slapping each other
around and beating each other up yeah
okay break it up and then just shake it
off like it wasn't like it wasn't even
happening okay didn't they go to work
i really did like that angle though but
yeah so
but i liked too
that they also had the angle of the drug
lord jeff fahey
uh he also has a wife and a daughter who
are actually just like completely
innocent people and good people yeah and
he's like just a total [ __ ] [ __ ] heel
to them yeah and so i like too that they
had that sort of like emotional depth to
it because dark man sees how
he treats his family yeah and is like
you know he's this good-looking rich
dude and he has like a really nice wife
and a really nice daughter and he's like
and i look all [ __ ] up and everything
and i can never have that so it's like
in you know you don't even know how to
treat them so he kind of gets obsessed
with like
rescuing them yeah yeah he's he's
wearing uh their the husband's mask yeah
and he impersonates them he like enjoys
family life through there but he's like
cool to them yeah and the family doesn't
know what the [ __ ] is going on because
that's what i'm saying that's what he
really i was like if he turned up in the
house and because i'd be like the wife
would be like why aren't you being a
dick usually you're such an [ __ ] why
are you being nice with no matter with
you that was a great that was a great
element to the story and i really would
have liked this to been to bend movie
two
yeah it would have been made a lot more
sense for this to be part two than part
three yeah the more i think about it the
more i think i think this was part three
i think it or part two i mean yeah i
think it was supposed to be but it was
just i don't know i don't know why it
makes sense that
it makes sense that the return of duran
is actually movie three because then the
series goes out with a bang that's yeah
exactly that's what i was saying and you
hadn't seen durant in a while yeah so i
think i think the order is wrong
yeah i mean
and like i said there's it's weird
because there's quite a lot of
information about the first dark man
obviously because it's [ __ ] sam raimi
but since the second two
went uh direct to video there's not
really a lot of info about them like
even the wikipedia page is like just
nothing it has like a plot synopsis and
that's about it yeah um
so i don't really know
i mean i do kind of know that they did
switch the order but i don't know why i
don't know if it had something to do
with maybe this one wasn't done or it
wasn't like ready yet or it wasn't ready
so it's like well we have this other one
in the can because it looks like they
kind of shot them maybe around the same
time yeah um i'm not really sure and
like i said they do actually kind of
reuse a little bit of footage not a lot
yeah um they actually they actually use
some footage from the first movie as
well but it's mostly kind of like the
when he has those rage freak outs and
they kind of do like the explosions and
like everything going red and skulls and
[ __ ] like that so they do use that a few
times like to show when he's like
wigging out i will say that having seen
all of them now
i will give the series
my star of approval
yeah yeah it is this is a good series
um imagine if
the evil dead
was a superhero cartoon movie
but not as cartoonish
evil dead yeah not yeah but it's like a
superhero movie made by the the do the
did evil dead it has that kind of
with a little with a little like side
order of universal monster yeah almost
like uh
family opera
yeah or something like that
little hints of robocop
to me i it felt like it
kind of the sci-fi angle
kind of felt a little bit like robocop
and batman
well robocop had a similar thing in the
sense that it was a dude that got all
blowed up and then like they brought him
back like as a cyborg and he still could
remember his old life and like you know
had like a desire for that and it's like
kind of tragic so yeah dark man has that
too and that's what i kind of liked
about this one is that it had that
element like he wasn't being like a
super creepy stalker or anything but he
seemed like genuinely
upset that this drug lord had this wife
and daughter that were actually really
nice and
he was he was just like basically really
abusive to them yeah and so he was just
kind of like trying to get them away
because he started to think well maybe
they're in danger which actually does
turn out to be the case yeah um you know
so so he's like thinking well i have to
get him out of there so he used like
various i think i'm going to actually
buy this as a three movie set
i would own this yeah i think it does it
was maybe i think shout factory maybe
uh put him out it's worthy of a couple
of years back yeah it's worthy of owning
you know if it comes in a nice package
or maybe a little poster with it or
something it's just a it's a good series
i respect it now
yeah well i like that it didn't really i
mean obviously the first one's the best
one but it's like i like that the other
two didn't really dip that much in
quality they're still about the same
both of them are still like totally
worth watching yeah and i was actually
surprised that the third one
um was better was actually like i liked
it a little bit better than the second
one like i said i like larry drake a lot
in the second one and i liked kind of
the plot of it but
this one i think the story was more
compelling there was more of an
emotional core to it um
dark man was in it more yeah and you got
to actually see him being kind of like
um
you know having that like longing that
he can't have that family because his
face is all [ __ ] up and it's like you
know they had like a beauty and the
beast thing because at one point like
the the drug lord's daughter is in like
a little beauty and the beast play yeah
which i thought was but that kid the kid
that was playing the beast like his
costume was like [ __ ] adorable i got
a feeling if you watch this part one
three and two then it makes a lot more
sense well maybe one day if shutter
leaves it on there we'll do that like
see i think it makes a lot more because
now that i'm thinking about it because i
was thinking about it earlier you know
when i was thinking about what we were
going to say about the movie and i was
just kind of like
yeah i kind of think because this the
this one the third one
ends kind of the way the first one did
because you know the first one was him
kind of like telling his girlfriend yeah
you know i just you know i'm like this
and i don't think that you can ever love
me like this and also i'm all [ __ ] up
like emotionally not just my face and i
don't want to subject you to it i'm
going to be like fighting criminals and
it's like you're going to be in danger
so he kind of like lets her go and the
same kind of thing happens at the end of
this one where he basically
they he kills the drug lord by throwing
him in an industrial shredder oh yeah i
look cool we were just kind of like i
was like are they going there are they
oh my goodness they're going there okay
the only thing that i'm thinking is that
part three
they um added the element of the liquid
flesh
yeah
so
it couldn't be part two
because
yeah but that would have been in part
three you know the liquid flesh shot
where they should pouring it that was in
the second one
that was that that's what i mean about
them like reusing a couple minutes of
footage that was in the second one pours
it in on this
yeah like i said it wasn't a big deal it
was mostly there was a sequence where he
stole a bunch of money because like in
the second one too like he killed a
bunch of like uh gangsters and then he
stole some money like from their deal
and that's what he's using to like fund
his research right so in the second one
he takes all the money in the box and
like puts it down like in the manhole
because he has like this big underground
layer right
and so
there's a sequence in the third one
where he's doing the exact same thing
he's taking like a box of money he's
putting it down the manhole and then he
goes down there and gets on his little
train car situation what that what do
they call that i know i'm sure it has a
name but where he goes down the down the
track to his lair and then he goes in
his lair and he's doing his you know
another trial of his skin and it's like
it's not working and he takes his face
off and hangs it up that's like the same
sequence but it's only like two or three
minutes long and i can see why they
reused it like i said you know it's
gonna be like a year or two between the
movies no one's gonna notice and it
wasn't anything significant but that was
another one of the scenes too was there
was the scene where he was pouring the
liquid on his finger and it grew back
and it grew back because at one point he
figured it out yeah and yeah they don't
know what you're talking about probably
okay he could make synthetic skin
but in 99 minutes in sunlight it would
it would yeah it was very sensitive it
was like really skinny it was more like
a mask you know
um
it was it was a skin like substance
well in the third one he
gets a super computer because that
doctor held in a gene splicer the doctor
let him use it
and he invented a new one
that is a liquid flesh that you can pour
it on on a burned body part and it
immediately goes to work and and
re-grows the skin yeah and it reattaches
and it's forever it's real skin
he had a jar of it enough to fix himself
but the bad guy stole the data disc
and he didn't he didn't have access and
he didn't have a backup he didn't have
always back up your always back up your
data
couldn't get his hands on the damn he
didn't he couldn't remember it all and
he couldn't get his hands on the
technology to do it again
and at the end of the movie
the little girl gets her face burned and
he uses it because her dad's a dick
dad's a dick he used it to heal her and
he didn't have enough for himself so he
just left his face so his face was left
[ __ ] up so he has to use the 99
minute
mask
yeah but he could have just poured it on
his head and he'd have been normal again
but the fact that yeah during the final
fight like with the drug lord uh the
drug lord he kind of like
he kind of like what does he do he like
knocks something over and he butts up
the busts up this um like a gas pipe or
something and his little girl falls and
the steam comes in like her face off
half her face off yeah not off but it's
like burns half her face like bad yeah
and so he you know when he's able to
recover this one little vial it smells
this big of uh of skin he decides to
just give it to her yeah he shows up at
the hospital the doctor's getting ready
to uh do a skin graft and he storms in
no we're not going to do skin grafts i
got something else and then i told him
i'm doctor or something or other and
he's like okay you take it he fixes it
with the liquid
and then
she's good as new good as new
good as new
and then and then the story kind of ends
on a cliffhanger like another movie's
coming
yeah
yeah because he's on he goes to the mom
goes to the ball on the roof and she
says i want to see what your real face
looks like
and he's like why and she's like because
i just do yeah and so he lets her see
his real face which i think is kind of
cool yeah and then he says something i
forgot and then then then the credits
happen well she says thank you yeah
that's right and he's basically like um
he says well there's like a voice over
where he says you know she was right
there but she was still like a million
miles away or something like that right
and he's like and i have to go back into
the darkness right yeah and ended on a
cliffhanger yeah
which makes me think that's where part
two is supposed to be return of duran
was supposed to happen right after that
because that one didn't didn't end on a
cliffhanger like that it ended like a
res like it was resolved
yeah because duranko got blown up yeah
although he got blown up in the first
one he still came back yeah i think he's
made it made a gag out of it never
[ __ ] explaining how he came back it
wasn't even a gag it was just like a
throwaway line the guy said i don't know
how anybody could uh
but yeah so it's just kind of like
hey you know movie magic yeah i mean
like i said i i i wasn't mad about it
but
yeah honestly
i don't know there was just something
about this one that i liked a little bit
better than the second one it was like
less
funny
because i kind of feel like the second
one because larry drake was in it and he
was such a good villain
um he had like a lot of really good
lines and so a lot of it was kind of
like i don't want to go so far as say
comedic but there was like a lot of dark
humor in it this one was a lot more
serious i felt like but i liked that
better because i i don't know i kind of
felt like it was like a good balance
between cause the first one had some
humor in it too but it was mostly
a lot more dark man in it yeah dark man
the man
dark man the man yeah that's what they
share with all this you get to know what
he's all about and all his problems what
his character is like dark man what are
you all about i'm talking about people
he pulls
you i bought him more in this as that as
the character in this one than i did the
second one yeah um
you know in in return of duran he was a
stronger character
it was writing you know yeah
and i'm i like i said it's the same
director i'm assuming i don't know if it
was the same screenwriters or not um
because it looked like they just did
both of them around the same time
because they were only like a year apart
but they came this one had more
character establishing stuff in it yeah
than than than return of duran
he was still just a shadowy guy running
around doing stuff yeah saying [ __ ] you
don't really know who it is per se
i mean you know who it is but you know
yeah you don't see the character
development right that much and i have
to say i liked jeff fahey as a as a
villain in this yeah i've always liked
him as an actor he's a good character
actor um i'd seen him like i said in a
bunch of other stuff i remember him from
psycho three
uh that's where i first saw him i think
but he's been in [ __ ] tons of other
stuff since then that was actually one
of his first movies
but um yeah he's great he doesn't like
there's a couple scenes where he kind of
like chooses scenery he's kind of like
very sardonic but so it's a different
vibe to the larry drake character but i
dug that too and like i said i really
liked the whole rich drug lord you know
who's a [ __ ] to his family yeah and i
liked that at that element to it as well
and he didn't have to be
right
he was just that's the way he was and he
was like just constantly like [ __ ]
around on his wife and like not even
embarrassed about it no because she just
like she yeah she like walks in on him
like banging the doctor or they weren't
really banging they were just like they
were getting ready to bang and um they
still had all their clothes on but um
yeah so she walks in and she's like you
know yeah it's something about all the
affairs she's had so he's just like yep
yep that's what i do that's that's the
way it is babe you know what i mean uh
but yeah he's just really kind of sucks
but um no i think it's a strong series
three good movies uh the first one is
the best one artistically but they're
all good yeah they're all worth watching
part three i think is the second best
one so yeah i'm gonna agree with you on
that yeah i'm gonna agree with you on
that i liked them all but just something
about this one just like edged it out a
little bit more for me i guess i i don't
it's hard for me to say well you know i
guess we've been saying like why why
that is but yeah but they're all strong
movies they make a good box set
i le i like too that they had the um
other than them also having the opening
credits being all the same i like that
they brought the little kitty back yeah
the little gray kitty from the first she
she was in or he i don't know uh was in
all three movies yeah and uh and nothing
bad happened to the kitty no so that was
because i was afraid every time i see a
cat in a movie now i'm just kind of like
oh [ __ ] something bad's gonna happen to
that kitty well because it usually does
especially a horror movie but they don't
introduce a cat in a horror movie
without something terrible happening to
it and i'm still traumatized from
[ __ ] shape of water so you know what
i mean
the bad [ __ ] happened to the cat now
that was horrible but um
that was like i was so bad
uh slasher fred said there was a dark
man tv movie that was so originally
meant to be a tv show spin-off yeah i
heard about that i can't remember who
was in it though i remember seeing
something about it uh and then jason he
be dead said i had the comic where dark
man meets ash from the evil dead yeah
they've done some dark man comics that
came out after
uh yeah and there was some crashes for
some crossover which is like really
funny because bruce campbell was
supposed to play i think it's great that
uh you have
these [ __ ] companies
spending
millions or billions of dollars for uh
intellectual properties so they could do
some superhero all right and this guy he
approved you could know you can just
make your own superhero if it's good
it'll stick you can make your own
superhero yeah i mean i'm sure there's
like tons of people out there making
superheroes that are lame yeah
i gotta have good names behind it you
gotta have the the productions gotta be
right
and the tone has to be correct it has to
be kind of artistic and it has to be the
right character for the right time
yeah yeah that just seemed that this one
seemed to like hit at the right time it
wasn't like i said it wasn't a massive
success
but
it was enough of a success that it made
like decent money and still has like a
cult following and had like i said comic
books and [ __ ] like that so yeah i had a
horror angle to something that was
basically kind of like the shadow or
batman
or um
phantom of the opera
and with a sci-fi element and it was
just uh
kind of had
you know [ __ ] gangsters
kind of like the crow it's just you know
yeah it did have a little bit of the
crow kind of in there too yeah
not quite as goth as that right you know
but they did a good job
and like i said
you know that
you're not going to [ __ ] beat the mcu
and make a billion dollar movie with it
but you got three good movies and
they're just it's an individual
character you know it's an original
character
you could probably get merchandise for
this movie probably still making merch
uh i think you can it's interesting
because i think for a long time please
correct me if i'm wrong i think i
remember reading this but i think for a
long time this was a universal film
and universal they didn't even think
about doing merch for this like figures
or anything until like way later yeah
and then like a company approached them
and said do you have the rights to do
that and they're like i don't know
probably and he's like well can i have
them and they were like sure
so and then they ended up like making
some figures so like universal they
didn't even like bother looking into
like the merch rights for this because i
guess they thought it wasn't a big
enough deal they don't know geeks but
well i mean this was like many years
later
you know somebody called somebody up and
said hey do you have you know do you
have the rights to darkman and they said
we don't know yeah and you know i'll
have to get back to you so they had to
go through this big like legal rigmarole
to figure out if they had like merch
rights
for this character and they're like oh
yeah it turns out we do and so this
company ended up and then they started
making like a limited i think they made
a limited edition figure and like stuff
yeah which like i said he'd be a it's a
that's a cool figure you know with like
the with his little [ __ ] bandage over
his face and like i said i like his
teeth he looks kind of it looks kind of
skull
yeah skull beats freddy krueger type
because he's all burned as [ __ ] yeah
slasher fred says one of these days you
should review the 1995 tv movie black
scorpion tv movie 1995 black scorpion i
thought i thought i'd seen a movie
called black scorpion on mst but i
thought that was like a really old movie
and i thought that was like a mexican
film now that i'm thinking about
familiar but
it doesn't it doesn't yeah i'll have to
look that up and see i'm sure it's not
the one i'm thinking of because i think
the one that was on mst was in black and
white oh it's been a long time and i'm
pretty sure it was mexican but
yeah that's the only black scorpion i
think of at the moment but yeah speaking
of phantom of the opera
that's what the show tomorrow night's
going to be about we're going to talk
about
kind of talk about the novel we're going
to talk about like the um
the
the author and like kind of the the true
story that it was kind of based on
like
was the phantom of the opera real that's
gonna be the show was it real yeah
because the the the uh
um the the author
what's the name gas on the road right
yeah yeah gasoline swore on his deathbed
that he investigated it and then it did
happen
and it did
fit
from what i remember reading it and i
went back through it and read it
listened to some of it you the there's
audio books on um youtube yeah we've
both been re-listening to the audiobook
yeah which man one of them is nine hours
long and that's that's the i'm about
three hours in right
and um
i was when i was reading i was like man
they're talking about a serial killer
you know
because and he's swearing that it
happened and this is before profiling
and i think they wrote this i think he
wrote this in 1909
or is it 1906 and he's talking about
something that happened 20 years prior
so you're talking
1880s late 1880s
and uh i think that was before
that was before j h holmes
the murder castle
and a lot of the stuff that the phantom
does is kind of like something hh homes
did
yeah i mean if they made this up out of
their head just out of their head i mean
you know
they did a good job of [ __ ] making up
a serial killer
yeah you know yeah we'll get into it i
think i think it's going to be a good
show okay that was it was a good idea i
thought so you know
because i love all that kind of [ __ ]
then we're gonna talk about like all the
movie adaptations and all that kind of
stuff so i don't know it'll be it'll be
fun
but yeah so
uh yeah so all of the dark man movies
are on shutter at the moment so if you
have shutter you can go watch them right
now
and tell us what you think which one you
like the best and everybody uh thanks
for dropping by today and we will see
you guys tomorrow evening for the
regular episode episode 293 so we'll see
you guys again tomorrow